hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
hey gagging it's your old pals uncle
Hank and Kippy Kevin James Ryan special
announcement the ru garbage patreon is
alive oh baby it is up and running clean
living go to patreon.com/scishow every
week we're gonna have stuff me and Foley
from the hard feelings archive we're
gonna do live streams the whole nine
yards get in while you can buy low sell
high what they say so check it out
everybody go to patreon.com/scishow are
you garbage we need this welcome to
another exciting edition of ru garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out if they grew up classy or if
they grew up absolute trash I am your
host H Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day here in Bluebell
Pennsylvania coming at you from my mom's
basement and I can't lie the old broad
can still make a meatloaf I'm gonna tell
you that right [ __ ] now my co-host is
hiding out at an undisclosed location
somewhere on the southern shore of New
Jersey ladies and gentlemen the brains
behind the operation
the bookkeeper mr. Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
still down here king of the boardwalk
can I [ __ ] stop me baby come get my
belt if you want it I'm a little cake
from here oh yeah I would for a while I
was the only guy down here but they just
opened the beaches and jaws dude this
thing is flooded with people now you're
gonna be reporting on people trying to
get them out of town [ __ ] my hair up
down there I'm a local dude I got Jersey
plates now and everything I traded them
in
well happy to be here guys thanks so
much for listening thank you for
all the reviews on iTunes all the
subscribers on YouTube full video is
available on YouTube please rate review
subscribe also if you're new to the show
go check out our previous guests we've
had [ __ ] if you're a comedy fan I
don't know how the [ __ ] I listen this
we have mark Normand Joe list Bobby
Kelly
Louis J Gomez [ __ ] I mean it goes on
and on all bers e so go check it out
everybody thank you very nice Kevin
thank you so much and we have an
absolute very very special guest we are
so excited to have him here on the
podcast today you've seen him in
trainwreck it had to be you inside Amy
Schumer difficult people tarantula drunk
parents not to mention 51 episodes of
the hit show billions is a Comedy
Central half-hour he's appeared on Conan
at midnight night train what's your
[ __ ] deal this is not happening this
week at the Comedy Cellar
Late Night with Seth Meyers The Daily
Show with Trevor Noah
not to mention he's got an HBO special
out right [ __ ] now called son of Gary
and he is the co-host of the amazing
show the bonfire ladies and gentlemen
the big question on everybody's mind
today is is he garbage give it up for
the one the only mr. Dan Soder that row
was uncomfortable for me it looked like
it was uncomfortable for him though
you're gonna run out of breath midway
through it it sucks when you have to
hear all the things that you did okay on
[Laughter]
sag insurance that was the closest I've
ever felt to winning the lottery was I
was like let me just go I would honestly
the first year I had it I'd beg let me
just go get checked out yeah dude that
sounds like bulletproof yeah I was like
let me go checked up and they're like
what do you want I was like yeah and I
was like dude this is [ __ ] what's up
like it was like getting a credit card
for the first time yeah you're looking
at it like it's an expensive expensive
restaurant menu like
yeah I think I answered your question
there because health insurance is a
[ __ ] Bentley to me yeah oh my god
sometimes this hurts can you touch it
and then just having uh just having a
doctor with firm hands be like you're
okay like the first year I was in sag I
thought that you just got it
automatically and then I find that you
have to make a certain amount to get it
[ __ ] then at the end of the year I
was like alright well I'm sure I have
enough I look at you got to make 17
grand dude I I didn't even think about
it because when I joined I knew that and
they were like you need to make a
certain amount and I had to join I was a
force drawing cuz I used to work at W
xrk in New York which was k-rock it was
free FM and then it turned to K rock and
I was a overnight ej there and that was
after and then I am I never paid my
after news I just never paid him they
were like you got to pay your after dues
and I was like living hand-to-mouth
ya know in comedy I was a waiter at Dos
Caminos and I was doing overnight shifts
and that was my money my main interest
was k-rock but I was doing more say two
or three shifts a week so maybe I was
making $400 so I'm gonna dollars and I'm
like I'm not turn around oh yeah
so for two years I just didn't pay after
and then I did live at Gotham on Comedy
Central know like we're gonna give you a
pass sag was like we're gonna give you a
pass you have to pay sag but you don't
have I was like great and then I did I
Amy Schumer put me in a sketch in season
one of inside Amy and also I was
supposed to do Conan and then I get a
call from my manager he's like hey have
you paid your set you're after do sit
alone they find you man they [ __ ] you
don't think you're [ __ ] find you
never thought about it and he's like did
you ever pay that it was like no why
he's like they're holding you I wasn't
allowed to film a me show held me they
were like Amy texted me and she's like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't pay your
dues and I was like and then they were
like hey we're gonna block you from
Conan and filming your Comedy Central
half hour unless you pay it so I had to
like scratch together borrow some money
because I wasn't making any more I was
doing stand-up but he was
yes make it [ __ ] that was like [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
and then $3,000 so I never even and then
billions comes around you know you're
eligible for insurance whatever because
I used to you got a monocle on all he's
got referrals up the ass baby yeah
someone explain to me what a
dermatologist does yeah you you should
for used simple terms for me like a head
doctor
guys a head doctor I'm like so you do
all the heads do you do everything up
here gadget dudes that just do the skin
did you know that they just you know
went to a tummy doctor it was pretty
good you put a flashlight down my throat
and told me I was sick well when I moved
from I was waiting tables one of the
guys I worked with my buddy Eli was like
hey you can go to this like 2007 he's
like you can go to Bellevue and show
them how much money you make and then
it's a non-profit Hospital so long so
they or they have like on nonprofit wing
I forget what it was but you go into
this room I showed her one of my pay
stubs from the waiting tables
she gives me this red card and I could
go see a doctor for $20 and it was like
that was it it was just $20 I think this
is $20 but dude the waiting room was
like it was [ __ ] insane it was you
know things where you're like I've
compared it to the cantina in Star Wars
that's the only thing yeah yeah yeah you
see people with like giant moles on
their head oh my god and then they're
looking at me clean-cut white dude and
they're like what are you [ __ ] doing
yeah you're here to honor the place yeah
I'm like
[Laughter]
what would you do for ABC News yeah
Undercover Boss a hospital hi my name is
Dan hospital the hospital yellow a fake
beard on it looks terrible
I thought you're gonna say I thought you
could go to Bellevue but you had to like
think that you were crazy you had to go
in there and like [ __ ] on the floor to
get to see a doctor so I've had a kid
because I when I was a kid and didn't
realize it no he's gonna I just feel
like in sixth grade like what the [ __ ] I
just like this is kind of [ __ ] up and
sick but I used to like the feeling of
heartburn when I was older I I started
smoking when I was 12 and then I started
like heavily smoking when I was 14 14 or
15 and 16 I was a pack a day until I was
30 I know kids yeah I smoked a pack a
day I'm like what are you smoking at
lunch break and then like yeah rip -
before the bus boss would pick me up at
like 7:15 good morning cigs as a
teenager it was [ __ ] okay okay dude
bro I'm talking preteen not a teenager
talk about me my boy Byron would sit
every morning you come over my house and
in one hand a tie was Salem light and in
one hand eighth of a Marlboro light they
gank from his mom and his stepdad and
then he'd come over and go pick a hand
and I'd pick a hand and then that was
your cigarette and then we would go to
the bus stop at 12 13 and just sit and
smoke cigarettes before the bus I always
I had this thought recently but how did
that bus driver not be like just [ __ ]
smoking through the 90s was wide open
dude you would see a kid smoke anybody
yeah whatever man used to buy kids
cigarettes offer them stuff for the
store I swear to God my [ __ ] thing in
eighth grade was on Friday after school
I would ride the bus home with all my
[ __ ] friends
everyone go drop their backpacks off I
would grab my Mongoose and then I would
goose kid not too by the way silicate so
Kennedy over here I promise you I know
the bike for this baby
the bike I had before there's an orange
mountain bike called mud and guts it was
from Target my mom huh
they were like toy bikes not real bikes
I wasn't gonna like oh my god when I got
the goose it was my mom was like you
gotta buy that Danny see Ragusa over
here dude what was that was the peg
situation okay I can't afford eggs I
just had the goose dude it's over one
with the black silver it was silver with
the blue Mongoose riding on it forget
what it was called
they all had names but um you know that
bike was man I [ __ ] even bringing it
up right now I know dude having a good
bike in the kid was all I bought so it
was like that was my bike you know what
I mean like it's like your pardon
yeah my mom was like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] grounded her back can't take my
[ __ ] bike away I bought that [ __ ] so
employee Darin and my mom and I would
have fights like that I mean I was an
only child of a single mom so it was
like those were our fights every day but
this I'm just kicked out talking about
smoking cigarettes because I used to
take my bike I used to take the goose
mom Zeus
I usually go down to Jason Coyle and
Nick Meyers Nicky Meyers and we would
ride up to sir Ector Meyers now I think
he's got like a business I think I think
he's like one of those like lawn doctors
you know I think gonna be a better
friend to people groundskeeper he's not
a groundskeeper it's like the step above
that like yeah like they bring
specialist in and be like this is the
Kentucky bluegrass you need this outside
I'm like the bunker on hole 9 that can
he's the sod whisperer
he so we used to ride up to Circle K and
then we would write on circle K's trash
yeah yeah we're not gonna have to ask
any [ __ ] questions this guy's telling
us everything
it's like we knocked on his door you
open up easy what took you so long
yeah spills as beans about being garbage
but we used to ride up and this was the
90s this is what you were saying how
wild the nineties were huh we used to
sit on the side weird twelve we were 12
and 13 we'd sit on the side of okay and
we wait for people to walk in and then
with $3 hey there we go
excuse me sir can you buy me a pack of
cigarettes you just ask like that you're
just one movement like sir can you
please buy me a pack of cigarettes
remember every guy that was like trying
to smoke over here dude the guys that
would say yes I was like dude you're the
coolest you thought they were the
coolest dude it's a lot of wifebeaters
you thought about all this [ __ ] dudes
[Laughter]
specify back hard pack you were doing
soft back as a dude if you're doing soft
back as a twelve-year-old you had no
shoes so I don't know if you guys
remember this in the 90s they would put
cigarettes on the counter
cigarettes weren't all behind like a
little display like a boy or something
so it's funny you say that because I
just remember mine
I think it was Nick or Jason had this
move where they had a starter jacket
right and they would like put their
hands knocked they put their hands on
the counter and then asked for and then
they grabbed a pack off the thing and
then just like put it in their pouch
like putting anything back on everyone
you know what I'm gonna get out of here
and it was always soft packs soft acts
were the ones that were always on that
counter so I remember and I used to put
them in mmm
knees yet a little paces support my
cigarettes that are Altoid cases yes
pretty sweet we we you did we did we'd
in the Altoid case and then that little
tube was perfect for Bernie's day to be
perfect perfect cigarette holder and
then in fact I have a scar on my [ __ ]
hand and I don't think you'll be able to
see it I would show you guys where in
person it was from when I was in eighth
grade in this girl Laura's basement
smoking cigarettes with all my friends
and I was burning do we used to do the
same thing we'd sit outside this place
of [ __ ] village tires and just
patellae and like wait for this the guy
you would always know he would pull up
he would leave his car on if somebody
was smoking you always ask them the guys
smoking but it's like some 22 year old
hopped out of his car left it running
running you're like this guy is a
[ __ ] mark right here yeah and if he
was playing rush loudly I could probably
get this guy to buy me a carton and I
don't have the funds well what we would
do is we would do that they were like I
guess this is I don't know to that and
late 90s I guess is I'm 33 so they were
like 275 maybe 3 bucks a pack we would
have a 5 like somebody would have a $5
bill be like hey man get yours and you
can like almost get a pack yourself so
you're like getting a free pack a seed
two dollars to buy you buy things but we
would spin it to another sig smoker like
oh you think you can get yourself back
sure yeah we had a homeless guy that
lived behind he like kind of lived
behind there but he would drift yeah
behind grocery warehouse which is like a
I grew up in like the burbs
I grew up in like a middle-class suburb
yeah but middle class kids are try to
explain to people it's like if they're
not rich even if they are rich but most
the time middle class suburbs are bored
they're like bored so they do bad yeah
yes they're like there's nothing to do
yeah yeah and like every one of my
friends parents both of their parents
worked every every one of my friends
both of their parents work so it was
like this omma there was no cell
there was no way of tracking so it's
almost like from 3 p.m. is 6 p.m. it was
wide open
it was lawless where everyone day and
don't you just know you kind of had to
be back in a certain time so you're like
if I'm going an hour away I gotta get
myself an hour to get back to my mom was
a totalitarian leader like my mom was a
[ __ ] I was scared of her so I would
be like dude this even if you say 5:00
p.m. to me I'm like you can go down your
spine yet yeah but my mom would get you
know would get home from work it'd be
like around 5:30 6 o'clock and so I'd
always be like did I got to be home by
then so you'd have the you know like the
spray the Cologne for the dryer sheets
we found where a good one out sheets now
sheets you could keep them in your
pocket they never knew it like you
didn't have to it wasn't over the top
either put on a paper towel roll to your
room it was when I started smoking weed
consistently at 15 bounce sheets were
like dude you can walk into school ready
and if I dusted with a bounce sheet I'd
be like no one's gonna tell me how to
smoke the blunt my record
it's the soda smell good today dude the
one I got caught with is you could uh
this is late 90s talk but you could go
online and buy a not this whole podcast
as I'm talking about the 80s and 90s but
if you you could buy a novelty ID which
low AAA if you bought is like I want to
say this is 1999 so you basically take
you go get a passport photo you know at
like a photo place you mail them a
passport Furnham of you you buy this
novelty ID and they send you back like a
driver's license with your photo in it
and this is before the scans and [ __ ]
this is before they scanned him so you
just get this idea that said I was from
Connecticut my name was Daniel Miller
and I was 21 female baby first thing
with n/a I was 16 and I had a fake ID
and I went and got a tattoo on my back
I got a tattoo I got a crucifix in the
middle of my back of course you did
that's what all the sixteen year old
knows how to get is a horse versa fix
also my mom my dad my sister were dead
and so I was like oh I'm gonna get their
tattoo I'm gonna get their initials on
my back so my mom was like whatever
that's why my mom didn't give a [ __ ] you
want to do that I went to the tattoo it
was the what was it call it was right on
Iliff in chambers and it was a mini-mall
tattoo shop called the tattoo shop I
want to say mm-hmm I was 16 years old
and I gave the guy my ID and he's like
cool man what do you want crucifix with
a banner and a soft pack did I already
have that come on I was buying booze at
this point and I was like and with the
banner around it that says soda and he
was like so traditional you know what I
mean
[Laughter]
but then I would buy booze for everybody
like I would I didn't even really drink
that was the weird thing I've wanted the
ID more for cigarettes and porn like I
that's what I cared about it was like I
wanna buy packs of smokes and be able to
go buy a [ __ ] VHS of porn at newsl
and I was like I don't why don't I
that's our buying booze and then like
people wanted to hang out cuz I had that
you know like yeah of course yeah all of
a sudden they were like oh like the
girls in my grade we're calling me being
like and then there'd be like people
would invite me to a party be like hey
can you stop by the liquor stores
I knew my [ __ ] worth you oh yeah I
was just a schmuck that had a fake ID
that's all I was did I went to this my
mom lives in the apartment complex right
by this liquor store so I Drive by it
all the time it was right on it it's now
closed but it was this massive liquor
store and I could my kegs there that was
really big I think my kegs of beer and
we could have keggers and then I could
return the keg and I had this fake ID
and it [ __ ] worked beautiful
I didn't even ID me after a while he
just knew me yeah just now yeah yeah and
I buy smokes I buy like two packs of
smokes
I never bought bolt
whole brands of cigarettes are always
bought camo lights in a box cuz that's
what I smoked so I wanted to make it
look consistent joy they're not gonna
buy cigarettes for teenagers old rather
go do that at a gas station so I'm not
gonna ruin the booze connect you know
what I mean dude in this place we gotta
hedge your bets crown discount liquors
[ __ ] massive it was a corner of a
mini mall it was the corner store
there's just his [ __ ] giant liquor
store and I remember I had like you know
a couple bottles like vodka tequila a
Crown Royal bottle everyone had given me
money
I had like two 12-packs I like Rolling
Rock cuz you know I'm garbage yeah it's
always a diverse order when you're doing
that when you're buying liquor for a
bunch of kids it's always a lot of weird
red flags that's got to go off at the
dude selling it exactly so you also have
to you have to buy big small amount of
things buy big so like if you're gonna
buy beer buy all Bud Light so it'll be a
dream but I had this Royal Rock had it
all mixed in whatever the guy behind the
so I load up this big box right this big
box of booze and I walk out in front of
crown discount liquor and I walk by this
gold blazer and I'm just like whatever
and I go to my car go to the party
[ __ ] weekend whatever we can find I
come to school on Monday and my best
friend Danny is like hey dude coach
Anderson or football he was like he saw
you come out of the liquor store with a
box of liquor and I was like man I'm a
cuz immediately my dear if coach
Anderson's mad at me don't give a [ __ ] a
semantical he didn't give a [ __ ] about
me I am what sucked is I knew that blue
I knew that blue crown yeah and then I
found out because coach Anderson liked
Danny and my best friend cuz he was on
we were both on the football team but he
liked Danny and he told Danny he was
like yeah I went in there and told him
like an art dude he's in charge of
children you know a scumbag doing the
right thing what does [ __ ] ya what a
piece of [ __ ] now my 30s are like
checks out but I never said anything to
him about it there's anything to doing
about it
and then there was this one afternoon
where he and I are walk is used as
security guard at the high school and
we're just like walking down the hallway
and then I had a can of coke and has
walked by oh my god just coke today
coach [ __ ] this we're out of it you know
because part of me you're scared of
adults as a teenager so yeah I'm sorry
I'm sorry the party was kind of like
funky for snitching and the party was
like you just they were teachers were
cooler back in the day like they think
he would he would go in and blow up the
spot so you couldn't get any more you
just still could make that joke with
them and he would get it
we'll call my mom yeah or have you
arrested which my mom knew I was
drinking so yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] that was
that was probably the best deal of my
setup growing up is once my mom and I
made amends when I was 16 and she was
kind of like you can just do it whatever
yeah just don't drive drunk
don't drive hi yeah here do it here in
the garage don't do it in the house hold
on one of the first did you ever sit on
a do you have a couch in that garage no
but we had several lawn chairs okay oh
that's even worse I think and we found
this thing called the bone phone which
was this old speaker dude I gotta look
it up and see if he can even see this
thing it's called a bone phone and it
was a transistor radio that was like a
belt of speakers on covered with this
like blue cover you know like a soft
blue cover and you attached it to your
dog and so when you would jog you could
jog with your dog it's like an 80s
invention like you just saw with your
jog with your dog while listening to the
radio I don't know how the [ __ ] meet my
friend dentists found this but we had
the bone phone and then the bone phone
was just that that was the music we
played played in the garage yeah while
we were getting [ __ ] up was from the
bone [ __ ] you're tuned into eighty 3.7
the bone but you're listening to cast
107
it is getting hot in her Nellie's garage
has no ventilation very hot her it's
funny we've had we've had a pretty
eclectic you know group as far as like
backgrounds on the podcast like City
keep between city kids and suburban kids
Kevin and I are both suburban kids you
know middle class and there was that
that that that is what like you know
brought everybody together it was
boredom and the city kids are fun but
the ones that we were late to more like
the reason we wanted to have you want I
got I got that vibe from you that you
were like you knowing I feel like my
judge role your childhood you know what
I mean yeah like just that that boredom
small-town kind of [ __ ] that's what
really makes the show yeah I think it's
um I think it was a weird situation to
be in because my mom is you know
educated and successful like she was a
medical malpractice mediator for years
yeah she's [ __ ] super smart in like a
badass just someone that's kind of like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'll take care of it
which is obviously why I was terrified
of her and it was just her and I for
most of my life so it was like this
weird thing where I was growing up in
the suburbs so on the surface I was like
this is really nice there's like you
know I mow the lawn every Saturday
alright yeah dog mm-hmm I go to school
with like a bunch of kids there's no
crime really in my neighborhood and I
would go see my dad and I'd be like this
is white trash crazy crazy
I've never related to a seem more than
in the departed when Mark Wahlberg's
talking [ __ ] to Leo about going to his
dad's house on the weekend different
accents I felt like I was like you well
the [ __ ] stole that from my life I
would go I would go to and I'd only see
my dad like once or twice a year I
really only went to visit him where he
lived in that Lake town where it was
super white trash probably four times I
think I went up there but every time I
was like it was like three weeks you're
like oh I like counts pretty garbage I'm
like to go up to a lake town if that's
not a good direction to not a good place
north north
man but it was it was funny because I
said this on stage one time but I truly
might have liked if you live near Lake
you either have all the money or no none
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
my grandma moved up there from San
Francisco back in 91 to retire she was
like you know she's 93 now but she was
like retiring and she uh you know up
near Clear Lake is like where a lot of
people from San Francisco used to go
vacation it was like back but back in
like the 50s and 60s they were like yeah
yeah yeah that's like the Poconos now do
you go there now it's [ __ ] you got a
trailer full of meth on you I've never
thought of that
til you just said that mm-hmm the
Poconos is East Coast Lake County yes is
trash now yeah dude cuz you go up to
Lake County and you're like this is
[ __ ] beautiful
he's beautiful and then you get a loan
in a gas station with a guy and you know
know how to fight you have to fight to
save my life did I saw a guy go I've
seen so many people ride bikes that
aren't doing it for the sport in a
four-lane highway it's never if it's a
BMX bike it doesn't have like the
mountain bike handles if you're if
you're a grown man on a BMX bike
broken-down mountain bike with a plastic
bag on the handlebars too so what's my
grandma retired up there I just have
been going there since I was in listen
she's got a nice townhouse she lives by
the lake it's [ __ ] nice where she
lives we retired there though that's the
day she retired there but he was trying
to plant a seed there Senate races flag
my dad was trying to do nothing but
drink and [ __ ] up there like that was
all my dad and it was he didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything so it was
interesting to have my mom who's like a
type personality and is like did you mow
the lawn did you take out the trash did
you clean the dog poop and you're like
yes mom I did that and she's like all
right you have to read John Steinbeck
this summer and you're like why do this
then my dad's like [ __ ] he got haters on
you brother
smoke em if you gottem that yeah let's
do it sort of God Jim showed it to me
and I was like I'm 12
who's this John Steinbeck [ __ ]
grapes am i nuts
my mom also dated so that was also like
a thing where you saw a bunch of Rando
dude come in you know what I mean and
then yeah because I was jealous of my
friends with married parents not cuz
their parents were married just cuz
they're weirdos where they're coming
over comin just hanging around the house
yeah and it's like it was always be like
my mom my parents are divorced I'd be
like nine thirty she's like yeah Joe's
gonna stay over I'm like oh dude the
worst was the [ __ ] hey Tom is gonna
be here for breakfast tomorrow
the only thing special don't [ __ ]
bury the question don't carry the
question that you're making a special
breakfast cuz special it's down yeah hey
you and Tom really seem to be hitting it
off what do you say we have breakfast in
the morning you know a story a story
that I completely forgot about until I
got into therapy was my sixth birthday
party my parents split up when I was
five and my dad moved to San Francisco
so it's just me and my mom in Aurora and
it was like my sixth birthday and Batman
was in theaters the original Batman and
Tim Burton's so it was all I wanted was
BAM it was like
that was all I gave me [ __ ] about on my
birthday it was like [ __ ] Batman and
I remember my sixth birthday my mom and
her boyfriend Tom [ __ ] my mom got me
the utility bill from Toys R Us the
Batman utility belt so I'm already like
yeah what a [ __ ] day I was like maybe
Tom will uh you know will play batterer
and then I noticed my my mom and Tom are
getting a little giggly right and then I
noticed that they're just [ __ ]
slamming mimosas and they just got
hammered on the morning of my birthday
and I just remember feeling that
uncomfortable feeling of like six and
it's like that's what's crazy to me
would be with people that didn't grow up
around alcoholics where they're just uh
I saw my mom drunk and it scared me I
was like you [ __ ] ass
I always hammered by the time I was
eight I was like ah the bag dude i legit
had my dad gave me the don't drink and
drive conversation while we were
drinking he was literally like I was
like 17 he like handing me a beer and he
already had an open one between his legs
he's like you shouldn't be drinking and
driving I'm like while there's open
containers my man let's do it dude we
moved we went we bought like a couch in
Boulder when I was like ten and my
stepdad Nick and I went and got it in a
u-haul and he was like do you want to
drink an O'Doul's and I was like what
and he's like it's a non-alcoholic beer
and it was like okay it he's like I
don't know I want one so I'll buy two
and you can distinctly remember driving
on back from Boulder to Denver
drinking the [ __ ] old duels with my
stepdad Nick and I was like now I'm like
Majan do imagine if you did that to a 10
year old rules and you give a
ten-year-old a dr. pepper now you're
[ __ ] go yes that has high fructose
corn syrup you do that we got to give us
some questions here I mean you gave us
everything that was a lot of information
it's gonna be hard to dig your way out
of that hole but and I'm honestly and
like just be like a warm feeling that
like my impression of like how I thought
you grew up yeah that you grew up like
that like I just I just like I said like
I'm using the might judge references
like the biggest thing that I can get it
close to that's the vibe I got because
you know what else - you know what Dan
where's the [ __ ] hell out of I've
ever seen Dan Soder in a t-shirt and an
open flannel buddy you wear that like
[ __ ] Han Solo
this guy's [ __ ] garbage sorry we're
gonna say that's blue-collar prom right
there I'm not gonna lie I think you
pushed me back to button-downs open
button-downs generally buy some [ __ ]
flannels and J was rocking some flannels
before the teen and I think I might have
to start doing
somebody if they were casting office
space now we'd be standing around like
Ron Livingston who you wear a nice
t-shirt and an open [ __ ] button-down
I that I believe get your ass kicked for
saying something like I would love to
what I think I'm gonna bring back after
the team is a thermal long-sleeve under
t-shirts oh I was just thinking about
that all right let's get into it
oh yeah let's give us some questions
here let's start with a cup just a
couple of the basics because we have
specific questions that we wrote for you
just take me into your mom's house it
was a single-family home I was in an
apartment no my mom bought a house my
mom my mom's a get [ __ ] done kind of
person I think that's the reason why I
have such a good work ethic is because
my mom was like sometimes would put her
work before you know thing that you take
care of you know you were talking about
from three to six how about in the
summers from [ __ ] 8:00 to [ __ ]
6:00
[ __ ] lawless those time would stand
still in the middle of some of those
days laws my mom didn't let me stay home
I had to go to after-school program
until I was 11 so I wasn't allowed to be
at home and and not just then it went
yeah it was so much fun but I also I was
lucky enough that I was in like football
so I would go to like community some
sort of structure yeah yeah there'd be
stuff where I could be like oh I'd stay
at friends houses but um yeah my mom got
us our first house we bought was a like
a three-bedroom two-bath in my
neighborhood in Mission Viejo like all
along the perimeter which is now like I
think that neighborhoods like starter
homes for like a lot of thing which
makes sense that's why my mom got it and
then my mom got into a thing with my
aunt about a little bit of money that
was left on my grandparents ain't do the
thing with an aunt is always a dead
giveaway number two have you ever fought
with a family member over money yeah
my mom was like hey you didn't give us
any of that inherent inheritance and my
aunt was like [ __ ] you I think I don't
know I was a kid when it happened but my
mom got my aunt to invest in this house
that I lived in from when I was 10 to 18
it was really nice there's a
three-bedroom two-and-a-half-bath in the
clean 11 right there circle it's pretty
nice
three-car garage all right you bring it
up that's big over here that's the
biggest one we've had on this show so I
had a two-car garage all right this is I
have it there couple of garages big of
big topic on this show three cars in the
garage or was it filled with [ __ ] yeah
well my stepdad was like a mechanic it
was like a guy Nick that we moved into
the house with that was a big thing for
him cuz he owned a house in like Denver
proper and like the montbello area and
he was selling his house cuz him and my
mom were married gotcha he was like with
that with you I think it was with his
old house my mom and my iend money for
my aunt they bought this house I feel
like a little bit of your communion
money was probably called fund but yes
she bought the house and my stepdad it
was like a really big thing that he was
like I want a three-car garage because
he would build [ __ ] like it was a
functional garage yeah for sure he built
my mom ice this is the coolest [ __ ] and
I should have spent more time in the
garage with my stepdad Nick cuz they
were married from when I was like 8 to
11 or 8 to 12 they were out there
married and he you know my mom a 1970
MGB with just the body like started with
the body and then got all the pieces
yeah and then built it and she sold it
like [ __ ] six years later it's like
you just built it he was like here I'm
gonna make you a $30,000 yeah here's a
bunch of money that's [ __ ] wild yeah
she ended up selling it to my friend
Joel's dad just by chance
well the car sounds nice but a big
staple question here on the podcast
a three-car garage Dan Soder inside that
garage did you have an extra
refrigerator yeah we had to well what's
in that refrigerator me man Sodor we had
two refrigerators one was a meat freezer
awesome that my mom would buy meat at
Costco and then just put it on a freezer
and pulling you know popsicles and [ __ ]
it was beautiful there you go
Brown had an orange light button on the
top right and then we had a we brought
our own refrigerator from our old house
and so that's always the second fridge
is always like some scraps once in the
second fridge what's in the second
fridge smokes so much weed in the
[ __ ] garage and people would see that
be like oh there's a water thing that's
such a trashy thing I love it
dude I go it's just so funny this is
just bringing up a lot of memories but I
remember we were riding me and the boys
were out riding Sings and jumping dirt
mounds baby was all about just a flock
of geese coming down the [ __ ] Street
and my friends did that thing you know
Jason took a quarter and they're like
let's ditch him let's go to his house
and steal sodas they went up the garage
and goes rid the bikes under the lawn
and then went into my roof that
refrigerator and were like taking sodas
or putting on the shirt and I remember I
was like it was half joke half like
seriously [ __ ] cherry cokes man I ran
and I try to tackle Nick and he I got
away and then my friend Jason I like I
turned him around at the refrigerator
and he just [ __ ] punched me in the
mouth she's like I turn him around and
he I was bigger than him
and I remember I just grabbed him by the
throat and pushed him against the meat
frigerators and I was just like [ __ ]
choking him right and he's like
and my stepdad hears all this and comes
into the garage and he's like I said
that was Nick was big he's like six six
just had a big deep voice and he's like
I was holding Jason by the throat and
then it moved his friends the next day
yes you [ __ ] cleared it up over a
Winston
I [ __ ] he rocked me and then I choked
his ass and then I was like all fun but
yeah they to refrigerate that might have
been
that's exactly been looking for that
answer on this podcast you just
described the garage fridge to a
suburban America is [ __ ] huge we
talked about in every episode and that
was the most perfect not to mention the
[ __ ] the the meat freezer next to it
where a guy got punched in the face
if you ever choke somebody out if you
live in the burbs and you don't have a
soda fridge okay anyone in your family
or extended family on a kegerator
friends of family not family okay all
right but I've been you know that was
the goal that was the holy grail if you
walked into a party and they had a
kegerator going yeah yeah I know some
friends of mine whose parents had one
yeah but I didn't you know it wasn't
like no one in my family had it my
family was a rum and coke family
aristocrats Captain Morgans Bacardi
that's what the sodas drank oh man the
glass the Bacardi with a splash of coke
and then my mom like Southern Comfort
Manhattan's on the rocks a lot of empty
SoCo bins growing up I love her she's
good now she's fine she's great I loved
growing up did any friends of yours or
family members that you know get
seriously injured in a dirt bike or ATV
accident oh dude honestly dirt bikes
cost too much money yeah yeah like I
think if anyone had that and I didn't
know anybody that had ATVs or dirt bikes
where I grew up
mm okay MSM in Colorado yes I mean like
people that live out like Parker and
like a place where you can be around
more or yeah but people anybody gets
seriously injured when you were riding
near Route riding near your bikes back
in the hall it's like jumping over
things I was the guy that always got
injured what's the scariest thing you've
ever jumped off on your bike when you
were a little Winston baby get into it
because of Luke he grew up off the
Highland canal which is like where
Columbine is and stuff this is where
combat is but he lived it off now and
there was like these dirt jumps by his
house awesome dude never just stumbled
upon dirt jumps in the woods they're
like the older kids had made or
something
construction site or something like that
that's exactly what this was there was a
construction site and these guys that
build a couple tables and a couple jumps
and I'm like dude this is [ __ ] tables
I've heard that in so [ __ ] long a
table I was like okay and he's like dude
they got these tables and he's jumps
from our house and he's I tell your mom
to bring the Mongoose out so we put the
Mongoose mattress in the back of the 91
4runner because everyone in Colorado
does an SUV and went out to my cousin's
house and I remember we were so excited
we got our bikes I put my [ __ ] in his
room we hung out and then we rode to
this [ __ ] jump and I remember seeing
this jump and I was like dude this is
awesome
see like go you do the jump and then
you're supposed to like go to the right
I like did the jump and then I went left
and I didn't realize that that was like
the lip of another jump
though I went left and then I just
[ __ ] just Facebook just went over and
I remember just going over there and it
was like my face hit the dirt and I slid
down but then you're more embarrassed
than your hurt oh yeah there's God up it
was like yeah
that's cool and then it's like Luke and
his friends I don't know these friends
but I know my cousin that's too good I
love it I knew we'd get to something if
it wasn't ATVs or dirt bikes I know
there was some [ __ ] dicey situations
on growing up did you guys own a VCR /
DVD hybrid [ __ ] you that was rich kid
[ __ ] you go over there first DVD player
I got was a PlayStation 2 yes yeah same
here also another thing did you just
have did you ever own just the VHS
rewinder I know Brian Mobley did dude I
remember show it's my buddy's house and
he broke it out when he got it for
Christmas or something that's where he
was like I got it and I thought I was at
MGM Studios I was like what the where
are we Brian almost ran me through it
cuz when we lived in our old house and
he like ran me through it like I got
hired somewhere he's like this is the
tape rewind rewind the tapes and we go
to Blockbuster with mom and she buys his
candy and new tapes and something to
remember now I gotta tell all you new
guys something to remember don't put the
tape in backwards cuz you'll ruin the
machine also I don't know why they hired
you to begin with dan bye guys guys I'm
gonna need you to unplug it when you're
done using its owner did you I get the
vibe did you ever work in at a video
store no but I worked at a pizza place
which is like that's very a suburban
pizza place and I would trade work to
put brothers on I live in Berkeley and I
would trade pizzas for porn at the video
store in the parking lot okay
[ __ ] awesome I think I a pizza I make
the pizza and I'd bring him a two-liter
and then he would like let me be like
yeah dude go take like four DVDs and I
old REO
16-17 how old was the guy 30 yeah
fast and loose dude he was friends with
my manager cuz the breeze of smoke
joints in the back and we all had the
same like you know the back of the store
was all like all open yeah yeah it was
all us and it was like that's where the
delivery drivers parked so we'd always
be smoking joints out there the shitty
suburban job man was a walking run both
time literally Stood Still it was took
forever I remember getting off a shift
there being like years yeah you just
never just got off that I feel like I
just got off that shift
[ __ ] I gotta make this one last run to
this house near Utah cool all right what
do you got Foley I wanted to ask you
I wear the tables for a long time as
well I know you waited tables in New
York specifically when you waited tables
in New York not this is a garbage move
but it's also an awesome move did you
ever get stiffed on a tip and then chase
the people out and really go what the
[ __ ] did you ever go after somebody that
stiffed you on a tip you would have been
fired immediately exactly now that's
later but I would do the questioning
God's of aggressive questioning well
yeah is this was all right all right the
one that broke my heart was I waited on
common when he was dating Serena
Williams okay and it was like a $260
lunch bill and I think we got like you
know those celebrities [ __ ] you over is
some Lackey put some wacky pays in
screws you know no everyone else that
paid celebrity was Tori Amos Damon
Wayans there was a bunch of celebrities
I waited on that were like fine I just
it might have been because it was a
party I don't know what's going on Danny
I think they only had tacos and
margaritas whatever it was a bummer
it was a [ __ ] bummer but there there
was one table I remember specifically
these we get a lot of Europeans I waited
tables round rides the OE and right as
the o8 crash happened so I was waiting
tables from 2007 to 2011 and so the
crash was right there and Americans
stopped going out to eat but Europeans
were like their money was twice what
ours was I had these like Romanian women
I think
here Eastern Europe it was a late
janitor and it was like a [ __ ] 90
dollar bill and I was just like I know
you're not gonna give me a you're not
gonna give me 18 bucks 20 bucks so I
just kept being like do you not speak
English because I was like and then I
started saying [ __ ] under my breath cuz
I get frustrated mm-hmm when they be
like can you bring that anybody here's a
check it's not looking at it me all
right you guys have a good one I just
talk fast if I knew someone couldn't
speak English because I would just want
to talk [ __ ] to him okay
they're gonna be like you're in a
[ __ ] take care of me or whatever I
went back and they left me a 40 percent
tip that was like god I felt garbage for
that yeah hey Conan left me a dollar
once 40 or 50 bucks big I mean this is
this was years ago Smith what I was
before the first time before I waited
tables it was on the Upper East Side a
lot of people if I ever get that show
don't think I'm bringing it to [ __ ] up
the second I'm done hey red let me talk
to you backstage are you good at either
of the following tailgate games known as
washers or bag Oh horn horn horn after I
was drinking mm-hmm came out right as
always quitting drinking it's played
professionally now I know
incidentally how I know that is because
ESPN has nothing to show and last night
I watched about 20 minutes of a [ __ ]
Oh God
I was beer pong I was big into Beirut
yeah Beirut that was huge when I was in
college like do me a favor rank these
from lease garbage to most garbage the
following items ready and there is an
order sure potato salad egg salad
chicken salad seafood salad
being the least garbage way it's chicken
tuna seafood and what else chicken egg
potatoes seafood no chicken potato egg
yes chicken potato egg seafood what
comes first I would say the least classy
is seafood salad excellent okay and
what's the second least classy egg salad
awesome
next chicken salad yeah potato potato
can go either way because if you make it
with Miracle Whip it's got some snap on
it but pretty try it's trashy ER
beautiful right now the follow-up
question growing up was it Hellman's or
Miracle Whip no I did Hellmann's yeah as
I grew older I learned to like Miracle
Whip but I hated it when I was a kid
when you were a kid you'd go to
somebody's house and saw America he'd be
like I'll just take a peanut butter and
jelly and it was called best foods on
the west coast that was the yeah it
wasn't Hellmann's mayonnaise it was best
foods so Jack so the song wasn't to
bring out the Hellmann's and bring out
the best it was bringing out the best
foods and bring out the best wait wait
wait stall the jingle no they're the
same company they just from marketing
yeah it's like how Carl's jr. is Carl's
jr. on the west coast but it's Hardee's
on I just hope my mind is [ __ ] blown
it's all been a lie Hellmann's is an
international nah man Hellmann's I think
it is now I don't think they call it
best foods anymore but growing up who's
definitely best foods Wow
that's [ __ ] they would do the same
song same jingle dude yeah I even heard
that I ever know that jingle in [ __ ]
20 years glass from the bath that
there's all those mayonnaise hate going
around you guys could [ __ ] suck well
that would that was perfect I mean the
heart of that question is really just to
find out where your thoughts are on
seafood salad now it's garbage I love it
I love the ceiling imitations
the u8 imitation crab yes like will you
go you'll go buy like a package of it
and just like eat it my girlfriend is
horrified yesterday because I said I
loved shrimp
cup of noodles my stepdad installed a
hot water nozzle in our house so you
know the insta hot it's the hot so I
loved cup of noodles and I would just
pour that into the hot let it sit just
have a [ __ ] it's the hot in the house
is [ __ ] that's for that ain't too
shabby right so one of your friends
doesn't know his drunken burns his hand
yeah I'll sneak up on him I just got a
few more questions here go ahead yeah
have you ever do a wedding at a VFW
no no but VFW's aren't really Wes
Colorado East Coast
the Patriots live baby yeah we do like
our chief golf courses the apartment
apartment club houses yeah like they
kind of the common place that's bad so
one of those hanging up like balloons in
the corner we had my aunt's 40th
birthday party at the townhouse at town
lines Club we do the Christmas party
every year my mom's [ __ ] townhouse in
the clubhouse there's tape from the
other parties still up on the wall in
the corner and [ __ ] still a balloon from
a birthday party the week before yeah a
couple of different colored napkins from
a christening for sure yeah alright
follow you go do you have anything
reversible you or anything reversible
dude come on my favorite [ __ ] thing in
the world was my reversible Jerry Rice
Jersey growing up he [ __ ] read it
either be home or the black with the
gold numbers come here I put a
reversible [ __ ] okay where do these two
items belong an open bottle of ketchup
belongs in a the fridge or be the
frig yes an open bottle of syrup goes in
the cabinet with a fridge cabinet
excellent alright very two classy
answers I like it I got another one
butter
fridge are out my mom kept it out yes oh
you gotta go fridge all day long that's
literally insane it's garbage but how
great is it to [ __ ] put nice warm
butter on there's no struggle I would
draw the line I think you could cute you
can't keep it out overnight maybe if you
wake up in the morning you leave it out
you have a breakfast lunch order
but overnight it sleeps in the fridge
talk to my mom dude she had no it only
stayed outside it was an outside dog how
do you feel about Hawaiian pizza yeah
all right
have you ever added a muffler racy or
racing stripes to a car nah man I had
the 8800 a quart hatchback in the 90 it
broke it broke down and then my mom and
I bought I did a pan or off but I split
a Dodge Stratus with me at night
yes d50 they all I think they only made
them in white do those things where you
to where you [ __ ] utilitarian so my
mom you know like the senior trip
hi everyone goes on a senior trip all my
friends went to Mexico after they
graduated it was a graduation yeah that
was like the graduation get from a lot
of the parents really guys can go to
Cancun on this trip and my mom was like
for graduation I'm gonna let you go to
Mexico and I was like that's [ __ ]
awesome
you know like I'm gonna pay for the trip
I was like that's [ __ ] great sweet and
then she got the check in late or
something happen or the check bounced
something to happen where she's like you
can't go what the [ __ ] man but I had a
loan out for this car you know what she
helped me buy the Stratos and so she was
really cool about it she's okay said she
can't go on the trip I'm gonna pay for
half of the strattice long run that's
better
and selling that car to moved to New
York in 2007 so it was waving it what
what the Stratus run back then 3500 not
bad shabby
did you put a head unit in that bad boy
[Music]
car reeked like cigarettes with old oh
yeah looking back on the CD how much of
a [ __ ] pain in the ass with a man
books I arrived in Tucson in 2004 and
they took a 200 [ __ ] CD booklet out
of my car and was very upset about that
did you ever know anybody I thought this
was real garbage but everybody got it
eventually anybody who had the CD
changer in the trunk yep where they had
like the 45 loader over and [ __ ] to
change the CDs you're like what the [ __ ]
I just wanna listen some Eminem dude
let's keep it moving yeah they pull it
out like it was a [ __ ] server I got
the files [ __ ] safety deposit box in
the [ __ ] trunk alright I think I only
got one more here um this was a big one
of the nineties I feel would you would
your parents ask for a receipt at the
toll booth for receipts on everything my
dad would be like hey the pee $0.35 old
and ask for a receipt [ __ ] we
don't get my mom's all about receipts so
crazy to me
I love it I my final question Kippy you
got one more now you're good but it is a
two-part question number one I believe
this is a Kippy from mrs. Kevin's from
an earlier episode you ever purchased
anything with marble miles but what did
you do with the camels camel dollars I
had a lot of and then I lost them I lost
them when I moved from Aurora to Tucson
because I'd been smoking for a while and
I was like I'll get some cool camel
light [ __ ] and then I lost them in the
move I was very excited about that very
very upset about that a lot of camel
dollars he's in therapy right now dude
if you had the mall bro sleeping bag at
a sleepover in junior high you
the [ __ ] [ __ ] I know we had the
cooler oh yeah Wrangler deep in the
thermos the thermos was bay to the
marble thermos was definitely had that
suede jacket that was going around a lot
come on dude did you ask that was
another question did you ever grow up
with a foosball table a ping-pong table
or a pool table pool table that we
bought at the mile-high flea market was
it full size are one of the smaller ones
full size old school [ __ ] concrete
three pieces of concrete I stepped out
of my mom bought it at the flea market
that's pretty good but our basement was
hurt that you couldn't take shots
you're like the maestro in there yeah it
was fun as [ __ ] I got good at pool for a
while my final question on the tip of
the the Marlborough miles is did you
have a subscription to Sports
Illustrated when you were a kid of
course of course
and what Sports Illustrated for kids
when I started and that's worse I kids
yeah
or I might answer your question right
here
I just told my girlfriend about this
story we were watching she and I were
watching the last dance and I was like
listen I'm uh kind of a hoarder like I
keep [ __ ] I hold on to things from a
gang from the time I was [ __ ] like eight
years old on I got Sports Illustrated so
when I got Sports Illustrated for now I
was eight I would save the big covers I
would be like oh this is important I'm
gonna put it in my closet and then I had
a box and then I had this [ __ ]
massive box of all old Sports
Illustrated's and when my mom moved to
her townhouse she was like yeah I got
rid of him I didn't think you wanted him
I had [ __ ] Jordan retiring the first
time [ __ ] with Anna getting traded to
the Chiefs I had all these like crazy
[ __ ] big moments in sports and my mom
was like yeah I did boy I was like when
that Sports Illustrated would come and
me and my brother it was like the [ __ ] I
remember like specific cover headlines
like the incredible bust and like this
dude it was [ __ ] unbelievable because
there was no internet no nothing like
that
would we we would literally look at the
pictures and read them like a hundred
times but my final question to you mr.
Dan Soder you ever have the Sports
Illustrated windbreaker or football
phone
didn't gotten either but loved the
football joke in Wayne's World 2 loved
the joke and Wayne's World 2 about the
Sports Illustrated football no Helen we
got it yeah when he goes and visits the
naked Indian man which hit Morrison and
he's like you phone got misdelivered
it'll be there did you never again as
you never get either one of those I
don't know we always just had a Sports
Illustrated subscription but I remember
I broke my shoulder when I was 14
playing freshman football cuz I sucked I
I remember I had to go to the hospital
and they gave me morphine and I remember
I was back i Sport illustrate it was it
was Peyton Manning senior year at
Tennessee and it was a cartoon drawing
of Peyton Manning wrestling a cartoon
Florida Gator yeah I remember that
and I was so [ __ ] up on morphine and
then percocets then I was like I read
the whole sports all-star news portal I
was [ __ ] great I was personal
straight and then I remember like the
next day accusing my mom's boyfriend of
stealing this what so I was like I was
like there's more Scylla straighted it
was like yeah I gave you this much I was
like you're lying to me I was like now
I'm like if he does a morphine you
[ __ ] tripping balls out of it that's
great so there was no Sports Illustrated
there was i I lost it in between my bed
in the wall act up on morphine
[Laughter]
oh my god that is too funny Dan Soder
man thank you for sitting down with us
you're playing are you garbage I gotta
say 100% garbage but there are Biagio
[ __ ] love it absolutely of course of
course
shitty and have shitty things happen to
you when you're young so you can
appreciate good things or older I'm
always under the impression even though
I hated doing it and it's my biggest
fear to go back to it but don't you feel
like everybody should have to wait
tables for at least two months very
humbling the wall would be completely
different it's very humbling experience
for someone to complain that you have
brought them back they just did chosen
wise guys I saw crazy well we go we'll
see what stay safe out there but thanks
for having me on guys
thanks I think you want everybody out
there to know and I think listen listen
to the bonfire a conversation radio
monday through thursday 6 to 8 p.m.
check out billions we've got new
episodes coming out every Sunday at 9 on
Showtime and please stream my HBO
special son of a Gary you know thank you
so much we appreciate you appreciate you
coming on Thank You Man thank you guys
outside fridges for life yeah drop
bridge rod for you guys thank you so
much we'll be back next week with a
brand new episode of are you garbage
Kippy you got anything for them
yeah please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes the full video is
available on YouTube please subscribe
there if you want to submit any of your
own questions for our you garbage a lot
of you are commenting on YouTube and
stuff like that you can but they'll get
lost so please send them to our you
garbage at gmail.com also I am at Kevin
Ryan on all social media and I am at H
Foley on ice on Twitter and at Foley
Graham's
on Instagram and make sure you subscribe
to our you garbage and on Twitter and
subscribe to our you garbage on
Instagram as we said great episode
I had that vibe that he was that you
know that's kind of where he came from
in the beer for sure that I've picked up
I [ __ ] loved it it's great this is
good episode great job Kippy thank you
so much and I will see you guys very
soon
thanks guys see ya